[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
Google is a company with a lot of money
and a lot of ideas and they often bring
the two together to make awesome public
projects that people like us can use 20
percent time is a perfect example of
that Google gives the employees 20
percent of their time to work on
personal projects and they continue to
get paid for it but there is a secret
division at Google and one that we
rarely actually see public projects from
they work on the most advanced the most
high-tech and the most shoot for the
moon ideas of the whole entire company
and that is Google X Google X has
maintained its secretive status in the
company for a very long time in fact we
don't know when exactly it began and we
don't know how long it's been a pretty
big part of the company but Google X is
definitely a thing but we don't really
know all that many facts about Google X
in fact most people working at Google
might not know that many facts about
Google X but without any further ado
here are five facts 5 true facts about
Google's X number 5 is that it is a
constant breeding ground for private and
secret projects now Google has plenty of
public projects that we all already know
about the Android Open Source project
you may have heard of it there are
plenty of products that Google makes
that you and I use every day but there
are up to a hundred projects being
worked on underground at Google X all
the time that none of us know about
including some people who actually work
at Google it's very secretive over there
at Google in fact one employee described
it as being run kind of like the CIA
where there are actually two locations
one in Mountain View California and
Google's headquarters there and another
for robotics specifically in an
undisclosed location and Google has to
be careful about how they talk about all
these projects going on with Google X
because of the investors investors don't
want to hear that their money is being
thrown into these crazy projects that
can either be colossal failures or
perhaps a revolutionary success they
really want to hear that their money is
being thrown into surefire things so
these are very very secretive for very
important reasons to Google so I don't
share this video they don't want you to
hear very much about Google a number
four is that there are several main
projects that they're working on right
now that they have outed as public and
you may have probably heard of these the
three main ones right now are Project
Glass Project loon
and Google's self-driving car you've
probably heard of Project Glass and
perhaps even Google self-driving cars if
you've been following my channel or any
Google related stuff for more than a day
or so but Project loon is one that's
recently surfaced where they're planning
on deploying millions of balloons all
over the world above the stratosphere
above the weather and above war planes
fly to provide instant access internet
all around the world and they sort of
ride the currents of the winds that go
up thousands of miles above the earth
which is pretty interesting but yeah
that's where we're going to find new
Google stuff above our atmosphere
apparently that's where they're working
that number three space elevators now
this is a concept that's mainly been in
science fiction as far as we know for a
long time but apparently Google has
actually been working on something along
the same lines with Google X now space
elevators for those of you who are
picturing an actual elevator just facing
your head it's basically the idea of
being able to transport data and
sometimes materials and maybe even
people to space without the use of a
rocket that's the main conceptual
skeleton of what a space elevator is so
I can involve just a cable that's
attached to a satellite that happens to
be connected to earth it's not a
physical elevator but surprisingly
enough Google's getting into this kind
of stuff they have a lot of people
working at Google X and you'd be
surprised just how much in-depth
research they can do they have a ton of
servers a ton of computers a ton of
information and they're able to
apparently go into the Astronomy field
with this whole Google X thing number
two is that Google does hire people into
the company specifically into Google X
some notables are Johnny Chun Lee a
specialist in human-computer interaction
who came to Google X from Microsoft in
2011 Sebastian Thrun one of the world's
top robotics and artificial intelligence
experts who worked on a driverless car
before it came to Google and Andrew
younge a specialist in applying
neuroscience to artificial intelligence
which is teaching robots and machines to
operate like people and even more people
have come from Microsoft and Nokia Labs
and all sorts of other universities in
fact like Carnegie Mellon and MIT and
Stanford and research heavy institutions
like that so people are hiring into
Google X it is growing just like
Google's growing and it's very important
even if it is very behind the scene
number one is the neural
network project this is serious stuff
believe it or not so apparently a group
of researchers at Google X were working
for a couple of years now with a group
of computers a large group of computers
mind you to essentially simulate the
human brain meaning it teaches itself
the network is made up of 16,000 cpus
and more recently it's sorted through 10
million frames of youtube videos of cats
to eventually learn what a cat is and it
actually came up with a picture of what
it thinks a cat is all by itself this
type of computer learning is pretty
crazy but it's actually the first step
towards actual useful artificial
intelligence a lot of people believe
that the next paradigm after you know
Google got to search first the next
paradigm would be artificial
intelligence and we've actually kind of
seen sort of hints and glances at that
there's actually a Google Chrome
extension which allows you to right
click on an image and Google search it
and it will do a reverse google image
search of what it recognizes in that
image and tell you what it's seeing in
that picture
so a lot of things that Google X even
though they're very very secret and
underground little parts of it will leak
out we don't really know where they're
coming from but they're definitely
coming from Google as we can see they're
being implemented in a ton of Google
services so there you go that's that's
Google X it's pretty interesting stuff
and go ahead and leave a comment below
what do you think is going to be next
out of Google X what do you think Google
X is going to come up with and at least
make public next either way thanks for
watching there's been a quick short fun
video but if you enjoyed definitely hit
that thumbs up button below and I'll
talk to you guys in the very next video
face
[Music]
you